[CLICK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSS DUFFER: We're
the Duffer Brothers.
We're the writers,
creators, directors,
producers of the Netflix
series "Stranger Things."
[CRUNCHING]
In this class, we'll use
examples from "Stranger Things"
and show you documents we've
never shown anyone ever before.
MATT DUFFER: You're
going to learn
how to develop a television
show, how to take it
from the seed of an idea to
an outline into a script,
and ultimately how
you sell that script.
ROSS DUFFER: We actually got
rejected at least 12 times
before we finally sold it.
MATT DUFFER: In real
time, we're going
to develop an unofficial
Dustin-Steve "Stranger Things"
spinoff idea.
This is not a real
thing, Netflix.
How about they find that
Dustin's dad is missing
and has been missing
for many years?
[LAUGHS]
Many, many months.
Many months.
MATT DUFFER: This
class is for the person
who dreams of telling
stories for a living.
It's everything we wish
someone had come and told us.
We think it can give you an
idea of how to get from A to B.
ROSS DUFFER: Yeah, I still
think it's pretty cool.
All right.
The lizard creature.
Huh.
We'll see what
the internet thinks.
[LAUGHS]